hey everyone um i'm back for another
video uh it's been a hectic week for me
i'm not gonna lie i have just been
non-stop drinking and uh throughout the
course of the week i've gone to jail
once or twice and probably flip-flopped
my sexuality three or four times but
nonetheless i'm here i'm making episode
50 and i think in terms of the systems
design concepts video this is going to
be the last one
it's been a really fun round on this
channel so far and i've gotten about 750
of you in two months which is
sweet honestly
so i'm gonna keep posting but it's gonna
be a little less frequent especially as
i begin to actually start work soon and
i'm gonna put a little bit more effort
into these videos and make them a bit
higher quality than just like a you know
pretty shitty powerpoint it takes about
10 minutes and so i'm gonna go through
basically all the super popular systems
design interview questions and uh we'll
get through it together and i'll be
using my good camera so that should be
fun expect a video in early june but for
now let's talk about how to actually go
ahead and crack your systems design
interview and the steps you should take
in addressing any question
okay handling interview questions so
basically it's important to have a bunch
of this knowledge surrounding systems
design so obviously you can talk about
it in an interview however if you know
you just have a jumbled mess of a design
or don't kind of approach the problem in
a systematic way then you're gonna look
like an idiot and you're gonna look
unorganized and it seems like you're
just not gonna be able to get your
thoughts together so let's talk about
how to actually go ahead and approach an
interview question because there is more
or less a pretty accepted or proper way
to do it
okay the first thing is you are going to
clarify the requirements of the problem
this is basically just going to say well
what is it that you actually want me to
design because the truth of the matter
is that 90 of the time all the services
that you know someone might say in an
interview question hey design uber right
uber does a million things you can't
design all of uber in 45 minutes but you
can design a pretty small part of it you
know without going into too much detail
so you have to quickly hone in on what
exactly it is that you want them to you
know
have you design and then basically you
know kind of go from there and figure
out all of the in-depth requirements
from that
so you should ask a couple of important
questions you know obviously the scale
um ask for things like the number of
users and the performance goals that
you're getting so you can kind of hone
in on which part of the application you
want to focus on
and then additionally functional
requirements so for example you know if
we're told you know design twitter
that's huge twitter is a ton of
going on i'm not designing their ad back
end but you know can we post tweets do
we have dms do we have images there are
all these features of it and you have to
kind of figure out which ones to cut and
which ones to keep because at the end of
the day your interviewer is only
interested in a small part of them
okay next capacity estimations so this
one i still have trouble with myself
just because i don't know it's kind of
hard for me to convert data to actual
bytes on a disk but try to just get a
scale of how much data you're going to
be storing based on the number of users
that you have
based on the number of you know say
operations that they're doing per day
the size of each operation so you know
if you're up uploading a ton of images
or image data you know try and get a
good estimation for the size of an image
maybe 10 megabytes or you know if it's
video footage maybe almost up to a
gigabyte if it's high quality or
something like that you know remember
that a character is just two bytes so if
you're storing in 140 character tweet
it's probably around 300 so you know
keep in mind things like that so
additionally it's important to ask the
ratio of reads to writes
the reasoning for this being that you
know if you have a super read heavy
application the design is going to be
very different than if you have a super
right heavy application if they say
there's only one write per 100 reads
you're probably going to be optimizing
for the common case which is reads that
being said if reads are very infrequent
or you're writing all the time you're
optimizing for the right case and that
completely changes what type of database
you might be using and the design or
maybe even the replication
type that you're using
additionally it's important to know the
number of daily users
um because you know that's kind of going
to be multiplied by all of these other
estimations in order to figure out the
number of you know say gigabytes or
terabytes that you need to store and by
knowing things like the number of
gigabytes or terabytes then you can kind
of start to talk about hey
this is the way that i need to partition
this is probably how many machines i
have to partition on because you know a
machine can say only have i don't know
10 terabytes of disk space per machine
or maybe you know 128 gigabytes of ram
on modern servers or things like that so
it's important to kind of get a sense
for that there
okay now we want to start talking about
api definitions so these don't have to
be super formal and you know don't waste
a lot of time here they're supposed to
generally be basic but the point is at
the end of the day you're going to be
exposing some services to clients
generally speaking for most of these
problems and when you do you just want
to come up with a really basic function
definition for the type of things that
your server might take in in order to
basically go ahead and perform this
operation
so again back to the twitter example if
you're creating a user you want an email
and a hash of the password
and similarly if you are going to be
sending a tweet for example you know you
just want the user id and the text of
the tweet obviously in reality there's
going to be a bunch of other stuff being
passed into these functions
but for the purposes of an interview
don't waste time here just write out
some quick stuff
next talk about data tables because
although we don't necessarily have to
have made a decision on which type of
database to use yet you do want some
idea of the type of schema that you're
holding so you can keep in mind what
information you'll have access to on a
given endpoint call keep in mind it's
totally fine to have multiple database
tables that's very likely in reality in
fact because we're probably going to be
using a microservice architecture so
having many database tables is totally
fine you know you can organize these
however you want but you just want to be
conscious of all of the things that we
mentioned before you know things like
partitioning replication etc etc
but um yeah just something for example
like a tweets table here pretty basic
there's obviously going to be a ton more
stuff in reality but you just want to
put in the bare minimum more or less and
you know it's fine to just mention that
in reality there would be much more
okay next we can actually start creating
a design
so pretty much in any given design
the biggest thing to think about is hey
how is my design going to be meeting my
functional requirements
and what your interviewer is going to do
is they are going to challenge you and
basically go ahead and say well
what if this is a performance bottleneck
you know what if this were to crash and
so because of this it's always important
to think about the following things it's
going to come up in pretty much any
systems design problem
and that's going to be things like load
balancing
because obviously you need to ensure
that your server is not getting
overwhelmed replication sharding
choice of database and also probably
just the general way that you split up
your services it's probably better to
not use a monolith in a systems design
round and
you know if you can explain why it's
useful to kind of use a microservices
design then by all means you absolutely
should it's fine to have a complex
design you just want to be able to keep
it relatively organized
additionally note the interviewer's job
is to grill you they're not just going
to sit there and nod their head while
you write out some design on the board
what they're there to do is focus on one
particular aspect of the problem and
basically say to you well why are you
doing this did you think this edge case
through did you think this edge case
through and your job as the interviewer
is to basically prove to them hey i know
what i'm talking about how do you prove
that you know what you're talking about
well you certainly don't just rattle out
some design that you already memorized
from i don't know rocking the system's
design
instead what you do is you have to be
able to list the trade-offs of what you
picked versus what you didn't pick and
trade-offs are kind of the central
concept of systems design no one cares
if you can design facebook messenger
unless you know why you chose say
websockets over long polling it's
important to be able to look at all the
other options and say here's why i'm
doing what i'm doing and not necessarily
that it's 100 better because there's
never no completely correct answer but
rather just you know this is why what i
chose is valid and isn't completely
infeasible
and so that's kind of the point of this
interview you have to show that you've
been thinking through these edge cases
and that the technology that you happen
to choose for this problem is actually
suitable for it as opposed to certain
other technologies it's possible that
sometimes there will be a better
technology and they even may mention
that but as long as you can defend your
choices to some extent you should be
okay
okay guys um i mean that's kind of it
for the systems design concept series
i'm going to start doing practice
problems like i mentioned and
really grateful to all of you that have
been watching so far i hope you've
learned a lot and i've been getting a
lot of really great feedback
and
yeah start listing practice problems in
the comments that you want me to cover
i'm probably gonna do the grocking ones
first but
we'll get through it together and it's
gonna be a good ass time so i'll see you
guys soon